>>LaFawn Bailey: Good afternoon, everyone.
[audience responds] My name is LaFawn Bailey.
I'm with the Global Diversity and Inclusion
Team. I'm also a member of the Black Googler's
Network. So, on behalf of the Network and
Authors at, I'd like to welcome you here today.
I have the absolute pleasure of introducing
D. Clarence B Jones.
His remarks today are titled, "Reflections
on The Legacy of Martin Luther King, Junior
and Black History Month." Dr Jones is a--.
I'm just gonna give you a few highlights 'cause
I don't want to ruin the conversation. But
he's a Scholar Writer in Residence and Visiting
Professor at the Martin Luther King, Jr. Research
and Education Institute at Stanford University
at Palo Alto.
He served as Speech Writer and counsel to
Martin Luther King, Jr. and was co-writer
of the "I Have a Dream" speech. He's also
provided strategic, legal, and financial consulting
services to several governments around the
world, including the Bahamas, the Dominican
Republic, Jamaica, and Zambia.
He has received numerous state and national
awards recognizing his significant contributions
to American society. He's kind of a super
star. He has also been a subject of numerous
television and radio interview programs, such
as CNN, the O'Reilly Factor, NPR, and BBC.
He completed teaching for the second time
of his successful course, "From Slavery to
Obama," at Stanford University's School of
Continuing Studies, Master of Liberal Arts
program. He wrote, "Behind the Dream: The
Making of a Speech that Transformed a Nation."
He's currently co-writing a book, "Where Were
You?" for the 50th anniversary of the assassination
of President John F. Kennedy. And he's also
a regular columnist on the Huffington Post.
Lastly, he is writing his autobiography, "Memoirs
of a Wintertime Soldier." So, without further
ado, Dr. Clarence B. Jones.
[applause]
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Thank you very much.
This is my second time here at Google. The
first time, I came to be with my god-daughter,
Soledad O'Brien. And so, when you had this
special program in, I had a chance to see
the campus and so forth as I said.
Anyway, I'm delighted to be here. I am honored
that you provided me with this opportunity
to share with you my views on the legacy of
Martin Luther King Jr. and Black History Month.
Very succinctly.
In 12 years and four months, 1956 to 1968,
aside from President Abraham Lincoln and the
Emancipation Proclamation of 1863, Martin
Luther King, Jr. may have done more to achieve
social, racial, political, and economic justice
in America than any other single event or
person in the previous 400 years of history
of our country.
My oldest daughter is a graduate of Brown
University. I have five children. Brown University,
Georgetown University Law School, and Wharton
School of Finance. Perhaps like some of you
today, at one time, she believed her subsequent
career opportunities and success were solely
because of her individual dedication and achievement.
With her newly minted, prestigious academic
degrees, she just knew she was bad.
[laughter]
Help me, somebody. Prior to Martin Luther
King Jr., America was like a dysfunctional
drug or alcoholic addict. We had become addicted
to racial segregation. We had tried to kick
our habit of dependency and addiction to racism
and institutional segregation.
With his tough love of non-violent civil disobedience,
Dr. King forced America's conscious to publicly
confront the contradiction between the reality
of how it treated 12 percent of its population--African
Americans--and those precepts enshrined in
our Declaration of Independence.
Dr. King's tough love enabled America to embark
on an extraordinary, peaceful journey to recover
its soul. He raised the consciousness of America
on the issue of race and gender equality in
America, making it possible for my oldest
daughter and many of you--white, black, and
Asian--to enjoy the opportunity and positions
you now have at Google.
America has been a country of slavery longer
than it has been a free country. The ideological
foundation of slavery was that the ancestors
of African Americans were of a different species
of human beings, inferior in intellect and
culture to that of their slave masters.
Slave owners had no interest in the language,
culture, or history of their slaves. It was
a criminal felony in slave-holding states
to teach a slave to read or write. Therefore,
slaves were deemed to have no history worthy
of transmitting from generation to generation.
The average white person and African American
was for decades educated in school systems
where most textbooks omitted or relegated
to inconsequential textual coverage the history
and contributions of generations of African
Americans to our society.
James W. Loewen's book, "Lies My Teacher Told
Me: Everything your American history textbook
got wrong," should be read by everyone who
has any doubt about the accuracy of my assertion.
Why no Irish, Italian, Jewish, or Scandinavian
History Month?
Irish, Italian, Jewish, or Scandinavian forefathers
and foremothers were not forcibly uprooted
from their native homelands and brought to
America in chains and endured a Middle Passage
aboard slave ships that killed an estimated
25 million plus during transport to our shores.
They and the forefathers of other ethnic groups
in our country were not enslaved by our national
government, or sanctioned by our national
government. To fully appreciate the magnitude
of Dr. King's contribution to our country,
we have to revisit an important crossroad
in the development of race relations in America.
In 1857, the United States posed this question.
Quote. Can a Negro whose ancestors were imported
into this country and sold as slaves become
a member of the political community formed
and brought into the existence by the Constitution
of the United States, and as such become entitled
to all rights and privileges and immunities
guaranteed by that instrument to the citizens,
one of which rights is the privilege of suing
in a court of the United States?
The Supreme Court of the United States, in
the decision of Dred Scott versus Sanford,
ruled that blacks, both free and enslaved,
were guaranteed no rights, civil, social,
or political by the United States Constitution.
Chief Justice Taney stated that blacks were
not citizens because at the time that the
Constitution was drafted they were, quote,
considered as a subordinate and inferior class
of beings and had no rights or privileges
but such as the government might choose to
grant them.
The court did not say that the Irish, Italian,
Jewish, Scandinavian, or the forefathers of
other ethnic groups were guaranteed no rights,
civil, social, or political by the United
States Constitution. Justice Taney continued
and said, "When the founding fathers wrote
the Declaration of Independence, the legitimacy
of slavery, quote, was fixed and universal
in the civilized portion of the white race.
It was regarded as an axiom in morals as well
as in politics. Now, this Supreme Court ruling
was superseded and overruled by the passage
of the 13th and 14th Amendments in 1865 and
1868, respectively. This was the legal foundation
underlying Martin Luther King Jr.'s moral
leadership to transform America.
That is, Section One of the 14th Amendment
which provides that all persons born or naturalized
in the United States and subject to the jurisdiction
thereof are citizens of the United States
of the state wherein they reside.
And that no state shall make or enforce any
law which shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of the citizens of the United States,
nor shall any state deprive any person of
life, liberty, or property without due process
of law nor deny to any person within its jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws.
Against the background of systematic exclusion
of the history, of the language and culture,
and other contributions of African Americans
to the development of our country, a month
devoted to reflecting on black history is
not inappropriate. A focus on our history
will also reveal the significant contributions
of white people, especially Jewish people,
to the struggle for our civil rights.
Jews played a leading role in the formation
of the National Association for the Advancement
of Colored People. Two Jewish brothers, Joel
Elias Spingarn and Arthur Spingarn, served
at varying times as the organization's president.
November 28th, I was watching the Presidential
Election returns at Palo Alto at the home
of a colleague of mine, Dr. Clayborne Carson,
who is the director of the King Institute
here at Stanford.
There were several people assembled when the
TV networks announced that Senator Barack
Obama had accumulated sufficient Electoral
votes to be declared President Elect. Several
persons in the room began to shed tears. I
was asked, have I ever thought I would live
long enough to see an African American elected
President of the United States?
I said, "No." However, I also said, "My tears
were not because of Senator Obama's election.
My tears were for all those persons whom I
personally knew who were no longer living,
but who had made possible the election of
Barack Obama." Black history has been written
from the struggle of black people to be free.
It includes not only the role and contributions
of people like Sojourner Truth, Harriet Tubman,
Frederick Douglas, W. E. B. DuBois, Rosa Parks,
Jimmy Lee Jackson, Ella Baker, Fannie Lou
Hamer, Hosea Williams, Martin and Coretta
Scott King, at all, but also several white
people such as Viola Liuzzo, Reverend James
Reeb, Rabbi Abraham Joshua Heschel, Jonathan
Daniels, Rabbi Harold and Marcia Saperstein,
and two young men from Manhattan, New York,
Andrew Goodman and Michael Schwerner, who
in the summer of 1964 went to Mississippi
to assist African Americans to vote.
They were brutally murdered by the Ku Klux
Klan in Philadelphia, Mississippi. John Johnson,
the founder and publisher of Ebony and Jet
magazine, and Martin Luther King Jr. may have
done more to enable a whole generation of
African Americans to look from whence they
came.
Their contributions to our country and who
they really are than perhaps any two single
individuals in the 20th Century. Bombarded
24/7 in print and in television with the white
Hollywood standard of beauty and success,
Ebony magazine sought to celebrate the achievement
of blacks in America and the black experience
in general.
Martin Luther King Jr. gave black people a
sense of purpose that they were somebody.
Yes, that indeed, black was beautiful and
that a racist could not ride on your back
if you are not bent over, but walking upright
and tall. Black history has been written from
the struggles of black people to be free.
Today, we witness the peculiar historical
attributes of the black experience becoming
the fuel that drives the engine of much of
the popular culture in America in dance, language,
fashion, sports, and music. In 2008, as I
said, Americans elected an African American
as its 44th President of the United States.
Maybe the power of the absorption and the
adoption of the historical experience of black
Americans into the mainstream majority in
America means that someday, Black History
Month will no longer be necessary, potentially
becoming an anachronism and an historic dinosaur.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
I'll take questions.
>>LaFawn Bailey: One of the first questions
that were posted is, in your book, you have
a chapter where you write about James Earl
Ray. And as you would say, it's truth-telling
time. In your opinion, what would Dr. Martin
Luther King Jr. say about his assassination?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: In my opinion, one of
the things he might say is that he would forgive
James Earl Ray, but he would not forgive the
United States government and media that would
want to perpetuate the fairy tale that James
Earl Ray was the sole, single person involved
in the assassination of Martin Luther King,
Jr.
And let me be very clear. James Earl Ray pulled
the trigger of the rifle that killed Martin
Luther King, Jr. But let me also be very clear.
The assassination of Martin Luther King, Jr.
did not result from James Earl Ray getting
up one morning on April 4th, 1968 and say,
"Today is the day I'm gonna kill that King
nigger."
That is not what happened. Martin Luther King
Jr. was killed with the James Earl Ray pulling
the trigger by the cold, premeditated, calculated,
conspiratorial determination of murder. He
was killed as a result of cold, calculated,
conspiratorial agreement of murder.
We don't know who the other people are yet.
But as they say, at least in the older generations,
there used to be a saying that the truth will
out. It probably won't come out in my limited
life time, but it will come out. It will come
out someday as to who the other people were
who participated.
A fourth grade educated person, convict, had
intimate knowledge of Canada, had intimate
knowledge of the geography of London, had
all these plans? Please. Give me a break.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you. Did you want to
ask a question?
>>MALE #1: Hi. Thanks for visiting us and
sharing with us. It's an honor to speak with
you. I'm curious about your opinion about
what is the greatest obstacle to that day
that you speak of when we don't even need
Black History Month because racism is forgotten?
What is the greatest obstacle to achieving
colorblind equality and what can we do to
confront it?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: OK. First, let me respond
and define because you use a phrase which
is frequently used and I've used it myself,
but I want us to be speaking in the same language
and the same baseline.
The concept of colorblind equality may mean
different things to different people. But
in the Martin Luther King Jr. sense, colorblind
equality means not that a person is blind
to color, but that the color is irrelevant
in the judgment you make on a person.
Anybody who tells me that I'm colorblind,
I would say, "Well, you need to go see an
ophthalmologist because you have a serious
problem."
[laughter]
OK? Colorblind, in terms of prejudice and
racism, really means we arrive at a point
where the judgment or determination as to
what opportunities will be made available
across the whole spectrum of circumstances--education,
housing, employment--is that the color of
the person who's seeking those opportunities
is totally irrelevant.
The only thing that's relevant is their qualifications.
>>LaFawn Bailey: I'll read a question from
our moderator page. "If you were to rewrite
the speech for today's audience, what would
you change, if anything?"
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Well, it's interesting
that you should say that [audience chuckles]
because one of the things I'm contemplating
is that 2013 is going to be the 50th anniversary
from the march on Washington and the "I Have
a Dream" speech and I am contemplating drafting
a 2013 version of what that speech might say.
But in direct response to your question, it's
hard for me to give a weighted sequence of
importance. I can think of one thing, for
example. Over the years, whether as a result
of a failed drug policy or whether as a result
of the unequal racist application of laws,
is that young black men who have run afoul
of the law for a whole combination of reasons--many
of them being drugs--constitute an overwhelming
segment of our incarcerated population in
prisons.
It is a national disgrace. Someone who has
studied this extensively is Professor Michelle
Alexander. She has a book out on this, which
I recommend, whose title I can't think of
right now, but she deals with I think it's
the rise of the--. I think it's "Jim Crow
and the Rise of the Incarcerated State," but
I may be wrong.
So, that's one thing I would change. And Dr.
King was a minister of the gospel before he
was a civil rights leader. And the intersection
of both of those things and his study and
commitment to the velocity of Gandhi made
him deeply spiritually, intellectually, and
totally committed to non-violence.
So, he would be appalled by the escalation
of violence. I might remind you that on April
4th, 1967, one year to the date of his assassination,
he gave a speech at Riverside Chapel in New
York before a committee called Concerned Laymen
and Clergy. It was time to break the silence.
It was his first public declaration of opposition
to the Vietnam War. And in that speech, there
was one sentence that was so powerful. As
you get down in like, the first three minutes
of the speech as you read it, it has a sentence.
It says, at that time, April 4th, 1967, calling
for an end to the Vietnam War he says, "The
United States today is the greatest purveyor
of violence in the world. Period."
>>LaFawn Bailey: It's still true.
>>FEMALE #1: Hi, Dr. Jones.
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Yes.
>>FEMALE #1: Thank you for coming today. My
question is this, and as you mentioned, unfortunately,
many of the leaders that you marched alongside
and worked alongside are no longer with us
today.
And obviously as time goes on, we're looking
for that next generation of leadership to
be that moral compass, if you will. So, I
wanted to know in your opinion, if there's
anybody that you see now as the up and coming
rising star? And if so, and even if not, what
advice would you give them?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: [sighs] Well, there
are lots of up and coming rising stars, a
new generation of leaders. But here, I'm gonna
have to give you an answer that I've given
ad nauseum. And so, maybe some of you have
read it or heard it because I've given it
on NPR.
And so, I have to just say it again. When
people ask me who, today, if anyone, do I
think is most like Martin Luther King Jr.,
I use the Latin phrase called "svi generis,"
which means one of a kind, unique. And I answer
their question with a rhetorical question.
Who today, if anyone, is like Galileo? Like
Mozart? Like Beethoven? Shakespeare? Copernicus?
Michelangelo? No one. If you were fortunate
enough to be alive from 1956 until April 4th,
1968, and metaphorically, you walked outside
at midnight and looked up at the sky and saw
a shooting star across the heavens, and you
saw a shooting star of such incandescent brightness,
a brightness that had never been seen before
by any astronomer or by you, that shooting
star was Martin Luther King Jr.
We will never ever, ever, ever, ever, ever
see that shooting star again in our lifetime
or in the millennium.
>>LaFawn Bailey: OK. Did you have another
question?
>>FEMALE #2: So, like possibly many people
in here, when I was in college, I did some
research and a paper on Martin Luther King.
And one of the things that I noted is that
it was Vietnam when he started talking about
Vietnam, that seemed to cause more problems
for him than anything else.
And also the Kennedys were starting to object
to Vietnam. And so, when you were saying like,
the conspiracy that James Earl Ray and obviously
the others, weren't the ones that organized
pulling the trigger. Do you think that Vietnam
actually influenced his death along with the
Kennedys?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: I think that his public
opposition to the war in Vietnam, I think
more on a continuing basis is beginning his
raising the issue of poverty and income inequality
in America.
It is important, some of you by looking at
your apparent age demographic, may not know
that when he spoke in April 4th, 1967 at the
time of his assassination, while there was
a great national outcry of grief, while subsequently
there were national monuments, the fact of
the matter is that he had become a pariah.
Even people--many leaders of civil rights
organizations--begin to publicly turn on him.
And so-called liberal friends, and this includes
people from the churches, it includes people
among civil rights organizations, and certainly
people in Congress, they, in effect, felt
that he didn't have the right that, "Who is
he? Just a preacher. How dare he speak out
and challenge the policy, the government of
the United States?"
The fact of the matter is that he had become
persona non grata. Now, with respect to the
Kennedys, I don't have enough time to say
and give the right nuanced response to the
question, but I will simply recite a historical
fact. And you conclude from that historical
fact whatever you wish to conclude.
From July 13th, 1963 to December 1967, on
the authorization of the Attorney General
of the United States, Robert Kennedy and J
Edgar Hoover every single telephone call that
occurred between Martin Luther King Jr. and
myself, from my home to his home, from my
home to his office, from his home to my office,
24/7 was wire-tapped.
And a written transcription of the conversation
written down so that you--. Let me make it
plain. When I was writing the first book,
the publisher--maybe it was the first or second
book, I can never remember--the publisher
said to me, "You know, Mr. Jones, we don't
doubt what you say, plus you signed an agreement
warranting us against any suits for anything."
He said, "But some of the things you say or
suggest based on what you say, and you appear
to have a pretty good recollection." So, I
said, "Well, that's not completely true."
So, whenever this instance would come up challenging
my memory or credibility, I would simply bring
in a photo static copy of the FBI transcript.
So, somebody will say, "Well, you said he
gave this speech in August in San Francisco
from the Mark Hopkins Hotel about this." And
I says, "Yes, he did." So, I just bring in
the transcript. The transcript reads, "August
so and so, 10:30 in the morning. Clarence
Jones and Martin Luther King, Jr."
It's just right on everything. So, what's
connecting it to that? It's tied into also
the first question, one of the first questions,
James Earl Ray. So, when Martin King was assassinated,
I'm saying to myself--. My first reaction
start when I got over the grief and horror
of it all.
I said, "You know? They knew everything I
was doing and he was doing 24/7." When I went
to the bathroom. By the way, it's included
photographic surveillance, not just--. I mean,
do you understand what I'm saying? There were
cameras, people with cameras, little telescopic
ones, taking photographs everywhere we went
when we met.
So, I'm saying, "If they can do that to Martin
Luther King and myself, you mean to tell me
they knew nothing about James Earl Ray?" I
rest my case.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you. I'll ask one more
Dory question here. It says, "At first, you
were hesitant to leave domestic tranquility--
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Oh, I know what that
is.
>>LaFawn Bailey: "to help a total stranger,
Dr. King. Could you talk about the important
role that your wife played in encouraging
you to get involved?"
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Well, I have to make
this, a long answer, short. But in 1960, Dr.
King was indicted by the State of Alabama
for lying on his tax for federal tax evasion.
And I had just gotten out of law school after
being in the military service after the Korean
War.
I didn't combat, but anyway, I had just been
out of law school six or seven months. And
his chief defense counsel got in touch with
me in California. He said, "We need a law
clerk to go and help us prepare the defense
of Dr. King. The only problem is you have
to travel to Montgomery, Alabama 'cause that's
where the defense of the case is."
So, I said, "No, I can't do that Judge." His
name was Judge Delaney. Fast forward is that
during the course of this, he arranged for
Dr. King to come to my home, not specifically
to see me, but Dr. King had a speaking engagement
in Los Angeles for something else.
And since his chief defense counsel said,
"Well, since you're gonna be in Los Angeles,
why don't you stop by and see this lawyer
and tell him what you're trying to do?" I
said, "Dr. King, come into my house." We sit
down and he--.
My wife was—who is now deceased--the mother
of my adult children and he says, "You know,
Mr. Jones? We have lots of white lawyers who
help us, but we need young Negro lawyers like
you to help us." And I said, "Well, Dr. King,
I'd love to help you, but I can't."
Anyway, I decided I just couldn't do it. So,
when he leaves--. I'm fast forwarding this.
I describe in greater detail in one of the
books. But when he leaves, my deceased wife
turns to me and she says, "What do you think
you're doing that is so important that you
can't help this man that came all this distance
to see you?"
And I said, "Excuse me." Her name was Ann.
I said, "Ann. That's not quite true. He did
not come all this distance to see me and ask
my help. He had a speaking engagement and
Judge Delaney suggested he stop by and see
me. And besides, just because some Negro preacher
got his hand caught in the cookie jar stealing,
that's not my problem."
[laughter]
"And anyway, if he wasn't guilty he wouldn’t
have been indicted." She says, "I don't believe
you." I said, "Well, that's how I feel." It
was a cold night in the Jones household that
night.
[laughter]
So, I went to church to see him be a guest
preacher. I mean, a guest sermon. This was
on a Friday night and Thursday night he came.
I'm sorry, Friday night he came. And then,
on Sunday, I went church where he was a guest
preacher. And listening to him substantially
changed my life.
But the answer to the direct question: Ann
Norton Jones had a profound affect because
she had a higher level of consciousness about
the importance of helping Dr. King than I
did. I was narrowly focused and only wanted
to get on with a career in intellectual property
law.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Well, thank goodness for
her.
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Right.
>>LaFawn Bailey: OK, next question.
>>FEMALE #3: Hi. You alluded to this a little
bit as you were speaking, but can you talk
a little bit more about how Dr. King's religious
convictions influenced all that he stood for?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: How his religious convictions?
His religious convictions defined to the core
who he was. He was a fourth generation Baptist
preacher. He was encyclopedic with the knowledge
of the Bible and of the Talmud. The "Dr."
in his name is for the PhD he had for a PhD
in Theology from the Boston School of Theology.
He used to remind those of us who were close
to him that he was a minister of the gospel
before he was a civil rights leader. An example
of how it influenced him was when we used
to be concerned about his safety. And he would
say, in effect, there is no man, there's nothing
on Earth that could be done to protect him.
He lives in the 24-hour protection of the
arms of his Lord Jesus Christ. There's no
need to protect. We were always concerned,
very much concerned, of his safety. President
John F. Kennedy was assassinated on Friday,
November 22nd, 1963. On the evening of Friday,
November 22nd, 1963, Dr. King and I finally
both spoke because he had been trying to reach
me.
And he said, "I'm being besieged by newspaper
reporters. I've got to issue some statement
in connection with the Kennedy assassination."
He asked if I could come to Atlanta. And I
said, "No, I couldn't." So, he flew up to
New York and we met at La Guardia Airport
in the Eastern Airlines lounge terminal.
And for three and a half hours, we sat and
crafted the statement that he would issue
on the assassination of President Kennedy.
But the very first thing he said as he was
coming through the lounge, coming down, deplaning,
coming to the lounge that he saw my attention.
When he got to me, he didn't say "Hi, Clarence.
How are you?" The very first thing he said,
he said, "You see, if they can get to the
President, they can get to me. So, let's stop
worrying about all this nonsense of protecting
me."
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #4: Hi. Towards the end of your book,
you talk about the progress that has been
made since the Civil Rights Movement. And
you talk about redressing some of the inequalities
that were the legacies of slavery and discrimination.
So, and I know this is a big question, in
your opinion, where are we on race in America
today?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: We have, America, has
come a long distance, a great distance on
the question, to use your words, on race in
America today. The election of Barack Obama
is just some evidence of that. And that the
changing demographics in the population, both
from age and ethnicity, is generally creating
a much more favorable climate for African
Americans and other minorities.
But in direct response to your question, unfortunately,
we have not reached Nirvana. Or, we have not
reached Shangri-La. Race still matters. We
wish it didn't matter. In response to an earlier
question, I said about the concept of being
colorblind.
I really would like for us to be today, February
15th, 2012, in Mountain View Google Headquarters,
I'd like for us to be in a country where we
could say without fear of contradiction that
racism against African Americans and other
minorities does not exist. But that simply
is not the case.
One of the things I think that moral leadership
requires, it requires the ability to see things
as they really are and not how we would like
them to be. Daniel Patrick Moynihan is quoted
as saying, "Everybody's entitled to their
own opinion, but you're not entitled to your
own set of facts."
There is, really going back on my legal training
and profession, a devastating bill of particulars
can be compiled about America on February
15th, 2012, that can be submitted in evidence
for the court or the jury determining the
question of whether racism exists.
Now, there is another question that hasn't
been asked, but I'm sure. And that is, who
is responsible for this? I don't, I mean,
I'd be, you'd think I was stupid if I came
up to you and said, "Well, there hasn't been
any progress." There's been major, major,
historic progress.
I can't tell you, I can't prescribe to you
the time-line when someone sitting in this
chair, or someone we can wake up in America
and we can say, "Today, we are America without
institutions, without any source of power
being directed against a person or a group
of persons because of the color of their skin
or their gender."
I am hopeful. I am hopeful because just as
America came through this whole transition
of struggling with race, we're now struggling
with the whole question of gender equality.
And when you listen and read some, when you
listen to some people and read certain articles,
you would think that the Republic is going
to disintegrate and come apart, you know?
I mean, I didn't know until recently that
the fact that a woman could love a woman or
a man can love a man and want to marry, that
that was gonna destroy the Republic. I didn't
realize that had such consequential effects.
I was raised as a Catholic. And I'm a spiritual,
religious person.
And so, I have a practical answer to all of
this anti-gay. I said, "You know, there's
some contradiction." I just came back from
Jerusalem. I visited Jerusalem and the Holy
Place and I said, "You know, there's some
contradiction on this whole question of gay
rights. If gay relationships were so bad and
gay people were so bad, per se, why does God
keep making so many of them?"
[laughter]
[applause]
>>LaFawn Bailey: Very good point. [laughter]
Thank you. I'm gonna read another question.
"Dr. King survived the Civil Rights Movement,
but was killed a month before the Poor People's
March on Washington. If he were alive today,
how would he try to change the heart of the
country on the issue of economic justice?"
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: He would say that that
is the central core question confronting America
today. Income, inequality, economic injustice,
as you say, I think that he would totally
identify except for activity of violence and
except for expressions of anti-Semitism.
Limited expression of violence. Limited activity
of violence. And limited expressions of anti-Semitism
expressed by the Occupy Wall Street. He would
identify that. He would get it. He would see.
I mean, as I say, you don't have to be brilliant.
You have to be deaf, dumb, and blind not to-.
Even if you can't read a lot, even if you
don't have a lot of education in political
science and history and so forth, but if you
just look around there's something wrong.
People, there's something wrong. My favorite
statement I say sums up my feelings. Notwithstanding
all of our debt and the public debt, notwithstanding
all of our, we're still an extraordinary rich
country.
So, I can't compute when I go back East, I
see it more than I see here, but I see it
here in parts of San Francisco. I can't compute
in my mind how this rich country can permit
a child to wake up hungry, can permit people
sleeping on the streets. It's not as if we
don't have the resources.
There is something wrong. So, the answer to
your question. The demonstrated, statistical,
data-supported information of the spread,
the disparity and the wealth, and the disparity
in income would be something that would be
front and center of his attention today.
And he would probably say that you--. Well,
yes. He would probably say. I'm going out
on a limb. I knew the gentleman fairly well.
He would probably say, "The dream that I had
in 1963 and the dream which I hope can be
realized in 2013 will never ever be fulfilled
until we deal with the question of income
inequality, poverty, and wealth disparity.
Never, will never be done. That's the challenge."
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you. All right. We're
skipping down a question. This actually has
to do with your previous answer about the
LGBT community. And it says, "Numerous parallels
exist between the 1960s Civil Rights Movement
and the present movement for LGBT rights slash
marriage equality. What do you believe we
in the latter struggle can learn from the
former? How best can we build movements that
are inclusive of all?"
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Well, the first thing
to do, however, is you want to avoid making
a profound political mistake. They have to
see the qualitative difference between the
struggle that was undertaken by African Americans
against the institution of segregation and
racism in the United States and the struggle
that the LGBT--lesbian, gay, trans-gender--communities
struggling.
There are significant differences, but the
fact that there are significant differences
does not mean that those of us who support
the struggle for gay rights can't look and
learn from some of the history of the struggle
for civil rights. They are very different,
but being very different, they also have something
very much in common.
And that is the elementary, it's so simple
and elementary and profound. And that is a
person should not be deprived of a millionth
of an inch, a scintilla of his or her rights
in the society because of their gender preference.
That is totally unacceptable. And as I said
to you earlier, I believe that it's very contrary
to the deepest religious principles.
And what confounds me is I listen to so-called
leaders of the evangelical and Christian church
and they have a whole theorem, a whole mindset,
that rationalizes why gays should not be loved,
why gays should be treated as second class
citizens. That is a corruption and a prostitution
of the teachings of the Lord Jesus Christ
that I understand.
Total corruption. Those of us from the Civil
Rights Movement, and by the way, I was so
singularly disappointed and actually blown
away when I learned that a number of African
American ministers in churches opposed gay
rights in California. So, I'm saying to myself,
"Where have these brothers been?"
I mean, sometimes an otherwise sane person
can have moments of insanity. So, that's the
only way I can explain it. How can some African
American minister in a church publicly go
out and say he is opposed to the rights of
gay people? It doesn't make sense.
>>LaFawn Bailey: When you wrote your controversial
piece in the Huffington Post, "Time to Think
the Unthinkable," you stated "progressers
might have to consider running a campaign
against President Obama in 2012." What was
your reasoning behind this statement?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: My reasoning behind
the statement was that I had, at that time,
had seen President Obama make what --, a number
of cumulative compromises--a number of compromises
that I thought were inconsistent with the
level of leadership that I believed he should
exercise.
And so, I began to think that--. The other
side of leadership, with respect to the people
you want to lead, there's an element called
accountability. You can't be a leader without
being accountable for your actions. And I
don't remember the particular. I think it
may have been the compromise on the Bush tax
cuts or one other thing.
But I found it to be, I found him to be, he
compromised in direct contradiction to what
he had campaigned on one or two issues. And
I said, "OK. That's it. I love the brother."
I said, "But there's something called political
accountability and the only way we can make
him accountable is to think the unthinkable,
is to raise the question that if he, at that
time, is not going to live up to the promises
and the hopes that he engendered in so many
people, then we have to think of another candidate
who will do so."
In a subsequent article, I then said, based
upon whether you read my article or not, but
I then softened it up. And I said, I was very
pleased. January 16th, I was in Washington,
DC and I was a recipient of what is Georgetown
University Legacy of Achievement Award, named
after John Thompson, at the Kennedy Center.
And the entire Kennedy Center, it was standing
room only. And the President and the First
Lady came and before the official proceedings
of the Kennedy Center, President and First
Lady came to see me in a private room at the
reception. And he came over to me and he said,
"Mr. Jones, I want to thank you so much for
everything you've done for our country."
And the First Lady said something about, I
can't exactly quote her, but some reference
to the Huffington Post. So, I guess they read
it.
[laughter]
>>LaFawn Bailey: There has been tremendous
social and cultural changes since the climax
of the Civil Rights Movement. What themes
and challenges from then are still present
today?
More importantly, is the future you see today
the future you envisioned back then?
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: No. The future I see
today is by far greater than the future that
we saw back then. I'll give you a classic
example. There were 250 thousand plus people
at the March at Washington. About 25 percent
of those people were white, assembled in front
of the Lincoln Memorial.
If in the planning of the march in the summer
of 1963, if we had a cell phone, if we had
a laptop, if we had a Blackberry, if we had
Twitter and Facebook and Google, you know
how many people we would've had at that march?
Not less than a million. Not less than a million.
The thing that we didn't foresee, that I certainly
didn't foresee, I didn't see the confluence
of the emerging communication technologies,
the power of being able to communicate and
message through multi-platforms that would
enable you to affect how people think about
things and thereby potentially being able
to mobilize them.
We actually didn't see that. The other thing
we didn't see is we didn't see that over a
period of time the great wealth disparity
that would occur. The other thing that we
didn't fully appreciate and see, we didn't
think that the United States Supreme Court
would hold fast to the interpretation of the
Second Amendment that was debated in Constitution
Hall in 1789.
It was the right to bear arms as enshrined
in the Constitution, did not contemplate automatic
weapons and uses and this great proliferation
of guns. So, we didn't see the proliferation
of violence. And the other thing we didn't
see was we didn't see that the United States
would, for a whole combination of reasons,
become awash in all sorts of addictive drugs.
And this has influenced--. First of all, it's
drained our natural resources. The War on
Drugs has been a total failure in terms of
significantly reducing or limiting drugs.
That is not to say there hasn't been some
improvement. But at what price? You have a
neighboring country that's almost a failed
state.
So, we didn't see that. And I would say the
principle thing we didn't see was that the
absence of real opportunity for all people
of all races and genders to overcome what
I call the poverty gap and the income disparity
gap.
>>LaFawn Bailey: Thank you. Dr. Jones, I am
humbled, honored, and inspired to have you
here today. So, on behalf of Google and even
the people you can't see that VC'd in, thank
you so much for joining us today.
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: Can I say one final
thing?
>>LaFawn Bailey: You sure can.
>>Dr. Clarence Jones: OK. You know, last,
on Dr. King's birthday, on January 15th--it
was earlier this year--I was very pleased
when Stanford University had a banner opening
across Palm Drive onto the campus that said,
"Stanford Remembers Martin Luther King, Jr."
Now, I am hopeful that in the next King holiday
that when I open up my laptop and I see Google
or Facebook, I hope I see something in Google
that says, "Google Remembers Martin Luther
King Jr." Or, "Facebook." I wanna see every
major company in Silicon Valley to do what
Stanford University did in displaying this
banner across the campus that said, "Stanford
Remembers Martin Luther King, Jr." Thank you.
[applause]